[Music]
forty years from now we'll have three
billion more people on the earth there's
a huge growing demand for energy energy
health care transportation cancer is a
complex disease tumor cells can be
incredibly hard to kill absolutely huge
challenges solving the most important
problems imagine taking quantum dots and
attaching biological structures to them
the new batteries that have been
basically built by viruses the solar
cell built on a piece of papers smart
bombs for cancer the truly heart
problems of science and engineering
don't neatly fit within the box of any
one discipline it's not gonna be easy
and it's gonna take determination new
science to be done new technology to be
developed new policies a new
understanding of our history insatiable
curiosity the imperative to solve
problems
everything we do encourages people to
think outside the box this is the
coolest place in the world if you want
to solve our problems
[Music]
Phobos is the innermost moon on Mars and
it's a really remarkable object it's
rather small looks a little bit like a
potato
it's cratered it's irregular the orbit
of Phobos is decaying about 20 meters
every hundred years it's actually on a
trajectory that will eventually spiral
in and break up so something's taking
energy out of the orbit of Phobos the
choices are that it's either the
atmosphere of the planet or it's the
interior of the planet it's a very
puzzling story and it's worth trying to
reconstruct I'm not an expert on
mysteric tides but we had a tide expert
in our department he said oh it's really
easy to calculate I have a program that
doesn't Maria Zuber is one of the great
leaders of space science the people who
are really successful at it like Maria
have to be of course terrific scientists
really understand the scientific
problems all of my degrees are in
science astronomy astrophysics
geophysics but when I came to MIT I
never thought that I would be getting
together with the climate scientists to
do research so we did the calculations
and showed that there is some
dissipation that occur from the
atmosphere and that was a key part of
solving the problem
one of the characteristics I think of a
really good interdisciplinary researcher
is that they have multiple vocabularies
but this means that somebody who wants
to succeed here has to be really
committed because you know you've spent
decades building up your expertise and
now you've got to spend some time making
sure you understand somebody else's it's
easy to think of interesting things to
work on but you don't always yourself
have the expertise to do it
but it's almost always the case that
somebody around here does people love to
solve difficult problems and there's a
real spirit of collaboration here one of
the things MIT has been strong at since
our founding is that helping people to
cross what otherwise or in other places
might be disciplinary boundaries as I
look at the great building that was
built in 1916 is really quite
extraordinary MIT started out since its
founding in the middle of the 19th
century in Boston actually in the Back
Bay and it had pretty rapidly outgrown
that area it had grown so large that it
was bursting at the seams and the
decision was made that you really needed
to have a unified campus there was some
land that became available in Cambridge
and we finally moved here in 1916 and so
there was a great contest over without
the soul of MIT what was his main
purpose and that was reflected in both
the site but especially in the types of
buildings a types of campus that would
eventually be built they commissioned a
study led by John Freeman Freeman was an
MIT graduate himself he'd been a member
of the class of 1876 he did studies of
universities all around the world one of
the problems was that departments
developed kingdoms they built their
buildings and even when the department
really ought to go away or be changed or
modified it lived on and
on and on any thought no you want to
have a building and then the departments
should shrink or expand as appropriate I
want to get massive functionality
efficiency function make this a factory
of learning we should have one massive
building okay we now call the infinite
card we force people to be literally
bumping into each other all the times
that would be a real firm n't ideas it's
not possible to know when you've left
the math department to enter the
chemistry department you can't tell when
you leave chemistry and get into
material science and engineering and so
we have lived on an architecture of
collaboration at least since the new
building was built nineteen sixteen
[Music]
forty years from now we'll have three
billion more people living in urban
environments in developing countries
that is a very very large energy demand
that needs to be met a major part of the
solution we are absolutely convinced is
solar energy one of the things that is
fairly challenging for solar cells is
their weight if I can reduce the weight
I might be able to make a roll of solar
cells and just unroll it like a carpet
and maybe staple eats to the roof
without having to reinforce that roof
Vladimir is one of many great examples
of the new generation of a researcher
who's very interdisciplinary he melds
together ideas from material science
electrical engineering and ideas from
policy all into one place he has found a
way of depositing a photovoltaic
directly on an ordinary piece of paper
all we need to do and I'm gonna simplify
it by saying all we need to do is simply
put a solar cell on top of that paper
Karen Gleason's work is beautifully
allows us to do that
Vladimir is heavily involved in the MIT
Energy Initiative particularly in the
Solar frontiers center and he approached
me when there was an opportunity to do a
project together on a solar cell my lab
works on chemical vapor deposition in
which you have vapors or gases that
absorb on a surface that's cool
nearly any paper can be used for making
paper portable paper take it cut it to
maybe a size that can fit inside your
chamber inside the chamber wonder
happens so the wonderful thing that
happens in there is gases get injected
they find a paper and they attach
themselves to that surface forming a
thin film the solar cells we make are
extremely good near the world record for
generating the amount of power for the
weight the next challenge for us is
boosting up those efficiencies by
engineering the cell inside I like to
say when I talk to my students that our
job is to be useful useful in generating
knowledge useful in generating leaders
mit has a problem-solving culture when
you talk about solving a problem out
there in the real world you rapidly
discover quite shockingly - some
academics that God did not organize the
world around a physics department in a
chemistry department and a mechanical
engineering department but rather draws
upon often all of these skills to come
together and that just means you do
whatever it takes to get it done the
origins of what we call
interdisciplinary work today at MIT
are rooted in the rad laboratory or
radiation laboratory it was a facility
that was plopped on the Institute even
before World War two started to conduct
top-secret research on radar technology
so the initial idea was to get a bunch
of physicists and buy a bunch they meant
about a dozen or two right to get a
couple smart people who knew about radio
waves put it in one place and make sure
they had the equipment they needed
sounds kind of simple right when the rad
lab opened in December of 1914 it had 20
physicists three security guards two
stockroom clerks and a secretary right
and about two and a half years later had
a staff of 4,000 we brought together
British American researchers we brought
together scientists
and engineers people didn't worry about
the labels they just worked together to
solve the problems and it was
phenomenally productive so it was really
a cross-disciplinary mix of truly
extraordinary proportion following the
war there was interested MIT and
maintaining that magic mix and the
research lab for electronics was
established as the follow-on to the rad
lab and even today the research lab for
electronics has faculty for many
different departments who all come
together around a set of problems and
because it has no real agenda it's a
collection of people it tends to have a
very creative atmosphere and it's just
naturally interdisciplinary and
interdisciplinary faculty gravitate to
it
we are very famous for interdisciplinary
laboratories think of the media
laboratory think of csail the Pekar
Institute the McGovern Institute the
Whitehead we are is well known for our
research centers as we are for our
departments and for our students and
faculty
[Music]
cancer is a complex disease and one of
the important goals for our work is to
try to understand that complexity and in
a sense simplify the problem one of the
unique things about tumour cells is that
they can be incredibly hard to kill
they actually have pathways that help
them avoid cell death what we're trying
to do with nanomaterials is find a way
to encapsulate a number of the cancer
drugs deliver them not to the healthy
cells but just to the tumor cells Paula
Hammond is material scientist who's
trying to develop new materials for
delivering drugs in more and more
specific ways when I first came to MIT
knew very few material scientists and I
wasn't even entirely sure what they did
to be honest with you even though I was
a physicist material science now is
incredibly powerful and Paula Hammond is
a perfect example of how bringing the
right engineer together with the cancer
researchers can really be a game changer
when we're working with nanoparticles we
start with a particle and solution and
nano layer by nano layer we grow the
film on the particle these nanoparticles
are very much like smart bombs for
cancer because you actually designed
them layer by layer to first target the
cancer and get that nanoparticle in
there once that bomb gets inside this
tumor we begin to release the drugs
which suppress the tumors ability to
fight and the drugs which kill the tumor
it requires this very huge and very
broad set of disciplines to be able to
do this mi t--'s talent base is
unmatched I would say across a range of
disciplines in science biology chemistry
physics and beyond and in engineering
most of our departments are ranked first
or near the top across the country and
indeed throughout the world and at the
Koch Institute I may have a graduate
student whose thesis committee includes
someone from cell biology side someone
from chemical engineering or somebody
who's and
D students are among the best glue in
the world they often will make the
connections between two faculty members
that suddenly realize there's a great
opportunity here one of the really
interesting requirements of all new
building construction is to consider how
it will be connected to the rest of the
campus and so there are many architects
that are stunned to discover that their
beautiful structures are going to have
to have a hole punched through at the
third floor to allow a connecting bridge
or cart or cantilevered from some other
building if you walk through Stata you
will find all these open lounges with
whiteboards with chairs with the idea
that that's a gathering place that's a
playroom I have seen startup companies
blossom out of an interaction between
two people who didn't realize they were
thinking about the same problem from
different areas and I've absolutely seen
students find new ways to think about
their problems on the basis of a
playroom conversation the Koch Institute
has and I won't say copied but has used
the same idea of having on every floor
these common areas to bring people
together the Koch Institute is in fact
the first of its kind in the country
it's the first dedicated cancer research
facility that has scientists and
engineers together and we have built
lots of spaces within the building to
encourage their interaction you've
basically got to get people out of their
labs if left to their own devices a
researcher at the bench will spend all
their time at their bench you have to
incentivize them and literally push them
out of their labs and that then you know
produces the sparks of the new idea
that's an essential element in the
intellectual churn of the place that if
you don't have that mixing component you
don't solve the kinds of problems you
want to solve
one of the things I've always loved
about MIT is its unique culture it's
always okay here to be completely and
totally absorbed by your science people
love what they do so much and they get
so excited about it that they want to
share it with everyone you have to be
fearless because you're going where no
one's gone before and everybody thinks
this is you're a crackpot or maybe not
they don't maybe they think you're
brilliant but whatever it is you're
doing it because you feel like that's
where you want to go the great thrill of
being here is having a conversation
where someone gets excited about your
idea and then adds to that idea their
idea and there is just an acceleration
of understanding I think it's easier to
collaborate across disciplines here than
it is anywhere else people who want to
solve hard problems who want to push
back the frontiers of ignorance who want
to create the future they want to be
here
[Music]